some of America's most exclusive schools
face a fresh review of how race is used
in college admissions one estimate shows
more than 43 percent of incoming
students at Ivy League schools were
minorities in 2015 that's up from 37
percent in 2010 the Trump administration
is now investigating a series of
complaints against Harvard claiming it
puts asian-american students at a
disadvantage in an interview you'll see
only on CBS this morning
Tony Jacopo's spoke to an Ivy League
president who says race should indeed be
part of the admissions process Tony good
morning good morning
earlier this year documents revealed
Princeton admission officers discussing
race and ethnicity of potential students
in stark sometimes uncomfortable terms
Princeton president says it's a
controversial process to be sure but he
also says a race-conscious approach is
necessary if we wanted to we could take
students who had only perfect GPAs and
only perfect board scores and fill a
class with them Princeton president
Chris ice Gruber will soon welcome a new
freshman class packed with some of the
best students in America but every year
his admissions officers are considering
more than just academics let's be clear
about this as part of our policy we do
take race and ethnicity into account in
building a diverse campus the Supreme
Court has ruled repeatedly that race is
an acceptable factor in college
admissions we want our students go out
in the world and have an impact in a
multicultural and diverse society and to
produce those kinds of students we need
to have a diverse student body on this
campus but a group called students for
fair admissions is accusing elite
colleges of discriminating against Asian
American and white students using
illegal caps on enrollment and higher
academic standards for admission in a
Washington Post op-ed the group's
president Edward Blum writes that racial
preferences punished better qualified
individuals and Pitt Americans against
one another
I had a 2030 and SAT not a perfect score
but still not bad I had a perfect
starting to a CT as well as a 4.6 7gp I
believe in 2012 Michael Wang applied to
almost every Ivy League school but was
only accepted to one had I been after
meri Latino my I might have gone to more
schools I'm not even sure myself
in 2015 federal civil rights
investigators reported no evidence that
Princeton University used separate
admissions processes reviews or tracks
by race but according to documents
released this spring admissions officers
did discuss applicants in racial terms
no cultural flavor reads one review of
an Hispanic applicant very few
african-americans with verbal scores
like this reads another can you
guarantee that asian-american and white
applicants are not being held to a
higher standard than other groups yes I
can guarantee that all of our students
are held to an equal standard it's tough
to get into Princeton that's tough to
get into our other Ivy colleges
regardless of what group you're from but
everybody gets a fair shake Harvard also
stands by its policy to consider race to
enroll a diverse class of students in a
statement to CBS News the university
told us Harvard's admissions process
considers each applicant as a whole
person and we review many factors
consistent with the legal standards
established by the US Supreme Court Vlad
Toni thank you